o ativa a tua energia descobre o sucesso
que a emc porquê porque eu acredito
fielmente que cada um de nós é cada um
de nós presentes nesta sala é exatamente
essa mesma capacidade a mesma
potencialidade talentos habilidades em
todo o sucesso e um futuro proibir
completamente dentro profundamente
dentro
todos nós temos essas habilidades o que
é necessário do fato é fazê-lo
desabrochar e é por isso que construir
sussex ana de que é muito em volta dessa
energia que mora dentro e nós temos que
fazer desabrochar o outro lado é que nós
vemos histórias e temos muitas histórias
de superação pessoas que acabaram por
suceder exatamente por causa da
superação porque exatamente porque nós e
como o próprio nome indica
superação é uma superação a regra geral
as pessoas que estão motivadas a superar
foram pessoas que encontraram terminar
desafios foram pessoas que encontraram
determinados obstáculos foram pessoas
que não tinham alternativa e não tinham
escolha mas na verdade tudo de nós o ser
humano nós não usamos mais do que 20% da
nossa capacidade e o que eu trago aqui
exatamente descobrir essa capacidade
inferior mas para descobrir essa
capacidade inferior porque muitos de nós
que estão aqui talvez alguns tenham
planos e planos futuros completamente
inscritos e concretizáveis eu não falo
do empreendedor que pretendo iniciar um
negócio o plano de vida
qual é o seu plano de vida quais são os
seus objetivos quais são os seus sonhos
com as suas os fatores críticos de
sucesso porque acha que é especial todo
mundo que gastar tem dentro de si algo
especial tem dentro de si um propósito
então
fato eu criei aqui opção os 7 peixe sete
princípios do sax anad
ele segue princípios logo nós vamos ver
começa exatamente pelo propósito qual é
o seu propósito qual é o seu talento
qual é a sua habilidade o que acha que o
faz diferente
depois nós temos consciência do nosso
propósito nós temos que ter determinação
para executar esse propósito
então o que nós temos que fazer é tão
simplesmente conquistar o propósito eu
acredito que toda minha platéia já
conquistou alguém já fez fundos e bens
para conquistar alguém 7 é verdade ou
não é então pronto este é o melhor
exemplo nós temos conquistar o propósito
nós temos que namorar com o propósito de
casar com um propósito
nós temos que falar com propósitos de
dizer eu antes eu quero que eu vou
conseguir
e aí será que fazem isso nas vossas
vidas muitas vezes nós desistimos
antes mesmo de ter tentado o maior que
podíamos
o mais que podíamos e é para isso que
nós temos que ter consciência do nosso
propósito descobrindo o nosso propósito
tem que haver a paixão nós temos que
chamar o propósito a mando o propósito é
isso que nos vai dar à luz a energia e o
alimento ea força para lutar pelo
propósito e é por isso que nós estamos
ter continuar muito apaixonados pelo
nosso propósito temos que estar
motivados planeamento
nós ouvimos aqui por diversas vezes de
diversas maneiras a volta do
planejamento o plano existe precisamente
para os recursos são escassos o tempo ea
mudança são fatores que nós temos que
enfrentar dia a dia todos nós só temos
24 horas por dia todos nós não sabemos
exatamente o que vai acontecer amanhã o
futuro incerto no entanto nós temos que
fazer uma gestão de prioridades
adequadas nós temos que fazer escolhas
em cada escolha um custo de oportunidade
o que o custo de oportunidade se eu
tomar a decisão de optar por uma escolha
tem que desistir de uma outra
o custo da unidade está no ted
é não estaremos amb a dar uma formação
sobre empreendedorismo e gestão de
negócios
esse é o custo por unidade nós temos que
fazer essa reflexão porque quando nós
tomamos nosso carro e nos dirigimos para
os lugares
nós temos que saber que nós temos um
propósito
será que isso está de encontro com este
propósito que nós temos porque nós vamos
ter que escolher vai ver tanta atividade
vai haver tantas prioridades se nós não
fazemos um plano
nós não vamos conseguir realizar o nosso
propósito
então o plano é fundamental para
assistir à práxis dentro do plano nós
temos planos de ação
temos ações concretas de atividades
concretas que nós temos que desenvolver
para conseguirmos atingir o nosso
propósito certo
depois nos perguntarmos exatamente o que
quando e como com nosso plano
nós temos que definir estas atividades e
aí vem a práxis a práxis é muito mais do
que uma simples ação é uma ação com
ética é uma ação com conduta é te tudo a
tem tudo aí está a nossa práxis o que
acontece é que no exercício dessas
atividades nós vamos errar nós vamos
falhar nós vamos tropeçar nós vamos cair
mas nós temos que nos levantar
nós temos que nos levantar é por isso
que a persistência é extremamente
importante não podemos desistir
nós não podemos desistir esse é
importante nós temos comprometimento
para começar é importantes nós temos
persistência consistência resiliência
para nós conseguimos chegar ao final
button nesta tecla cruzeiros e as falhas
elas vão acontecer mas dias por esse
experience ando nem vai do em aprender
fazendo
nós vamos progredir nós vamos avançar
passo a passo nós estaremos cada vez
mais próximos do nosso propósito
estamos completamente casados com o
nosso propósito e se isso acontecer nós
vamos lutar todos os dias mesmo com os
defeitos mesmo com os problemas mesmo
com os obstáculos mesmo com os desafios
nós vamos manter o mesmo
amor pra chegarmos até o final e aí
chegamos a professa chegar à perfeição
significa que o sucesso é igual o nosso
propósito significa que os planos que
nós desenhamos nós concretizamos
exatamente no tempo que imaginávamos de
forma eficiente com eficácia
significa que é possível dia-a-dia
conspiração e motivação chegamos aonde
queríamos chegar no início e agora nós
nos perguntamos então onde está o botão
conectar um botão que ativa a energia
onde está o botão que ativa o sucesso
onde está então esses são os três eps
que são 30 é extremamente importante são
fundamentais força foco e fé não mais do
que acreditar com formas de
transferência mas como é que nós
praticamos a motivação do dia a dia
primeiro temos que pegar numa lista é
que são as listas dos nossos 10 fazer
isto todo o início do ano colocar os dez
objetivos que nós pretendemos preciado
não é fazer a lista falar como já não
escrever a lista numa agenda escrever a
lista khullar o meu quarto olhar todos
os dias
invocar se eu vos contar a quantidade de
coisas que aconteceram na minha vida com
essa lista
cisne vão assinar eu casei me na altura
criativos filhos que queria casar com o
marido que queria conhecer as pessoas
que eu queria ele realmente estancados
ver que era uma coisa que eu desde o ano
passado
portanto façam essa lista e do final da
ta men ti o que é necessário para
conseguirem atingir nossos objetivos
invoquem é dito muitos de nós sabemos
que o mundo conspira a nosso favor nós
emitimos a nossa energia
e nós recebemos de volta essa energia
existe existe uma energia do cosmos e
esse sucesso vai se aplicar a minha
vontade o meu objetivo meu propósito vai
cruzar um outro propósito está a conexão
vai haver uma conexão de sucesso vai
haver uma conexão lideranças vai haver
uma conexão de energias e invoque o
vosso objetivo mas para invocar em você
tem que amar e pra amar tem que ler e
promar tem que fazer como vocês fazem
como é lavar os dentes vestir ponham os
votos de objetivos no âmbito do hábito
do dia a dia
se assim for certamente vão conseguir
dar os passos necessários
eu vou deixar ficar algumas dicas muito
rapidamente
primeiro é ter saúde para ter saúde
alimentação saudável esse descanso já
sabem 2 dar atenção às relações
familiares
por que vocês não são animais que vivem
sozinhos dentro de um espaço individual
nós temos relações interpessoais nós
estamos dentro de uma sociedade e se nós
tivermos bem com os nossos parceiros
também vamos devolver essa energia boa
3 talvez a mais difícil deixem de
reclamar
deixem de reclamar porque na verdade se
nós temos empregada que nós temos fomos
nós que tomamos a decisão de escolhê lá
se não estamos satisfeitos mandamos
embora
mandamos embora agora é preciso perceber
que a energia da reclamação e vou dar um
exemplo e vai meu filho meu filho não
sabe estudar meu filho está perdido
quando eu faço uma declaração destas
para o universo
eu estou a perder o meu filho não saiba
estudar e pequena exatamente aquilo que
estou a pedir é que vai continuar
universo então tirem essas pedras
reclamação das vossas vidas
deixem de ser vítimas a culpa é do
sistema culpa do meu emprego a culpa da
universidade a culpa do meu professor
deixem de ser vítimas porque a única
coisa que nós controlamos é o nosso
corpo e nossa mente
nós não controlamos nossos inimigos nós
não controlamos os obstáculos que
encontrou pelo caminho
nós controlamos por onde é que nós
queremos ir e eu estou a sair desse
espaço janeiro não sei se vai ser no
teto mas foi só isso continuar mas
deixemos de ser vítimas das situações
4 nós aprendemos com as referências
procurem aqueles que são os vossos
ídolos dentro da área em que gostariam
desenvolver copiem por que ocupe a ocupe
ar é o primeiro exercício de
aprendizagem
depois passo a passo vão conseguir ter a
nossa própria identidade 5 estejam
sempre plenamente motivados conforme já
havia dito prática não há motivação e
ficando criem um plano financeiro não
venha agora dizer que a não procuro não
goste já só para empreendedores não nós
temos que ter um controle saber mas
quais são as despesas fixas que está em
qual é a renda que o pago do meu filho
alega ainda que o pago em casa com as
minhas despesas extraordinárias e tem
que ter essa noção de onde é que vem o
meu e cam quais são os meus prometido
tem que ter essa noção porque por que
poupar poupar e é extremamente
importante e poupar não é poupar grandes
valores poupar é guardar alguma coisa
ainda pequena que seja de uma forma
constante ao longo de um período de
tempo
isso se chama poupança ea poupança é
fundamental se nós queremos investir se
nós queremos aprender se nós queremos
adquirir conhecimento e poderia
continuar uma lista infindável mas o
mais importante conforme referenciei é
acreditarem nas vossas capacidades
porque cada um de nós que gastar tem as
capacidades liderança
nós somos os donos das nossas vidas nós
somos os responsáveis pela nossa vida e
não é fácil ninguém disse que isto era
fácil se fosse fácil nóbrega bill gates
se fosse fácil não haveria mandela se
fosse fácil não via steve jobs se fosse
fácil não haveria o ted price fosse
fácil novo pça
o dia não é fácil e é por isso que devem
continuar a trabalhar que devem
continuar a acreditar que devem
continuar passo a passo casados com
vosso propósito que devem todos os dias
permitir lhes a si mesmos de aprender de
cheiro de abrirem o vosso coração para a
conexão para parcerias pra aprendizagem
e se não conseguirem voar e são os
guiarem andar gatinho e não conseguir
engatinhar rasteja mas não parem
continua em movimento em direção ao
vosso futuro e repitam quantas vezes for
necessário começando de um início que
vos faça mais feliz isso não chegarem ao
fim é porque ainda não acabou e se não
chegarem o fim é porque ainda não acabou
o saxon no dia descobre o sucesso que a
gente
[Aplausos]
ah